[Music]
we are celebrating the 40th anniversary
of Star Wars if you could even sum up
this weekend in just a few words I mean
what would you would you say
overwhelming just electric energy the
passion these people have are what makes
it so special who could imagine you know
and I don't see this in my everyday life
so when you see it concentrated into
such a small space it's moving really at
home you know you wouldn't see posters
from the movie or props or anything you
wouldn't even know that I had any
association the Star Wars and after all
this incredible fan frenzy in four days
time it's back to take the trash out and
go pick up after the dogs in the
backyard decidedly unglamorous time for
the Jedi to end why is it time for the
Jedi to end well now see if I told you
that they would track me down cut off my
head and throw it right in my face I'm
not allowed to say anything like that
but nice try if you're gonna tell
anybody it should be you know
entertainment a night watches
Entertainment Tonight everybody working
with Daisy Ridley and you guys are gonna
be spending a lot of time together in
this film how has she changed from the
first film to now well she's got a grip
on it better than I did I think she
seems to take it in her stride I think
she could probably a little more guarded
which is smart because like I say people
parse everything you say and do but when
I look at Oscar Isaac and Adam driver
and John boyega all of them don't know
Gleason you know people say did you give
them advice I said I want them to give
me advice because they are so together I
mean in a way I wasn't the first time
around you're like I'm still figuring it
out I know I add my hand
you